[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: The speaker
for today is Abhishek.
Abhishek manages the engineer
team building the Kubeflow
platform and
supports the mission
of Kubeflow to make
scalable LM models
and applying them to production
as simple as possible.
He originally worked
with Google Search
on crawl and indexing
systems, and then
spent few years with
enterprise ML startups
before he returned back
to Cloud AI platform
and is now working on Kubeflow.
Abhishek, take it away.
ABHISHEK GUPTA: All right.
Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE] and Shantru.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome, guys.
Thank you for showing
up and also apologize
for the little bit of delay
we had, but we'll start.
And I think Shantru
already kind of
give me the model how to
communicate with the audience.
I would like to be a bit
interactive if possible
and I might ask you a
few questions on the way.
OK.
I think the first thing--
we all here probably when we
talk about machine learning
what do we want to really
do, the first thing
that comes to mind is we
want to build a model.
How many of you
are data scientists
or consider themselves
data scientists?
I see one there.
Lower than what I expected.
I'm sure that I'm more
data scientist here.
Anybody else?
How many of you are
engineers or people
who productionize models?
OK.
A bit bigger group.
Great.
Thank you.
I'm sure you've all had
different experiences doing
this but everybody has
probably faced this.
You start with
thinking that you are
going to be building a
model, and the moment you
start doing actual
work, you realize,
well, there is a
lot of other stuff
you have to do around
before you can even
get your hands on TensorFlow or
something to train your model.
You start with data and
you have to figure out
where to get data
into your system
from data analysis, data
transformation, validation.
Actually, creating test
sets, training sets, then
training a model, building a
model, experiment a lot of it.
And then you want to
validate your model
and figure out
whether it actually
does what you are looking for.
And after that, you
want to train at scale.
Roll out the model production.
If it doesn't go
into production,
I don't know why
it's [INAUDIBLE]
to train the model at all,
so I think that is probably
the most important step.
And then, actually, solve
it and build probably
an application around it.
Of course, then,
eventually you want
to monitor and have
logging, as well.
So what's the problem in
this work flow, in the space?
Setting up an ML stack or a
pipeline is incredibly hard.
Anybody who has
done this, I think,
would agree with me that when
you start doing the serialize,
you need to install
a lot of tools,
either on your
desktop, workstation,
wherever you're working.
You get subbed into
a lot of engineering
and that [INAUDIBLE] where
you need to install and get
things connected, working
together, figure out networking
and I don't know what not.
Talk to production engineers.
And doing this on production
environment is even harder.
You have to be careful,
you're not messing things up
that are already there.
If you productionize your
model in the wrong way,
you might end up with making
completely wrong predictions
from what the data scientist
intended when they actually
trained the model.
And setting up an
ML stack that works
across different clouds
or different deployments
is extremely hard.
In fact, I don't
know how if at all
is possible with the
current set of tools.
And for our current purposes
for today's discussion,
we will consider your local
laptop on your desktop
to be multi-cloud, as well.
It's just another
instance of the cloud.
All right.
If we look at our
experimentation stack,
when you are building
a model, you're
training locally, trying things
out, you have a lot of stuff
running on your laptop
and enabling you,
starting with hardware at
the bottom with accelerators,
operating system drivers,
runtime, and then storage.
And on top of this, you
have your frameworks
that you actually use to
train and build your models.
On top of the stack, on
your laptop or your desktop,
you're going to be installing
a bunch of micro services
that enable you to compose
and create your workflow
all the way from reading
and data, training,
and then testing out your
model and making predictions.
Now, we take it a step further.
You've got to do this
whole thing over again,
where you actually want to
train your model at scale.
We all would love to train the
models with the volume of data
that we have available.
The more data
sets, the more data
points you are able to use.
Hopefully, you get better
accuracy in your model.
And then, finally,
you actually want
to deploy your model onto
cloud, where actually the end
points are accessible to users
and they are actually making
a difference in the real world.
The actual intention
of your model.
For all three of
these environments,
unfortunately, right
now in the current set
of technologies
that are available,
you have to literally
redo a lot of the stuff.
What you did in your
experimentation stack
to actually build
your model is not
exactly what you can take
to production or to deploy
on the cloud.
And there's a ton of work
involved in making that happen,
which is why we thought
of building Kubeflow.
And we started this effort.
Our mission literally is to
make it easy for everyone
to develop, deploy, and
manage portable distributed
ML on Kubernetes.
So in summary,
essentially, the platform
is going to allow
you to run Kubeflow
wherever you can run
Kubernetes on whatever cluster,
whatever cloud,
whether it's on prem
or some kind of cloud platform.
If you can run Kubernetes on it,
you can deploy Kubeflow on it
and take your technology
stack along with it,
including your local machine.
So you can run Kubernetes on
your local machines, as well.
With this technology,
essentially, this
is what your stack
should look like.
You are literally working
with Kubeflow services,
and whatever you
deploy and develop,
you should be able to translate
it across all the environments
without much effort.
Looking at what's going
on inside Kubeflow,
we have a bunch
of micro services
that we rely on in
building our ML workflows.
And we have integrated a
whole bunch of components,
some coming from Google itself,
from TensorFlow DFX and others
from open source community,
including things like TF
Transform, Numpy, Spark
for data transformations,
TF Data for data
validation, Jupiter
for actually a development
environment where
you experiment and build
your model, TF Job, MXNet,
PyTorch to actually
train your model at scale
and TF Serving, Seldom, TensorRT
for serving your model at scale
with the kind of
latencies you want
and Prometheus for monitoring.
There is more stuff that
we can't fit on the slide,
but also, you will notice
there are boxes which
are right now missing contents.
So we do need to build
out more competence
and get community
to get involved
and incorporate their
solutions into the platform.
All right, so that was
kind of the back story
on what Kubeflow
is about and how
it kind of lets you
translate your solutions
across different platforms.
I want you to spend
some time on this slide
and think about, like,
what the user experience is
going to look like.
People who have done
development of models,
we want to kind of like see
what is the work flow you will
be going through when you are
trying to figure out how you
develop and build your model.
One of the important
goals of Kubeflow
is really creating a low bar
and high ceiling experience.
What do I mean by high ceiling?
If you notice the way
Kubeflow is designed
on top of Kubernetes, it does
not restrict any Kubernetes
level APIs.
And in every tool that
is available on Kubeflow,
you should be able to configure
to your heart's content
and in whatever
environment you are on.
There is a lot of complexity
in Enterprise World,
a lot of challenging
networking setup,
and different kind of
environments that you
might have to optimize for.
And the configurations
in Kubeflow
should allow you to be
able to go down into detail
and modify whatever it
is that you need to make
it work in your environment.
But on the other hand,
you want to enable
users who are not familiar
with Kubernetes to be
able to access this platform
and be able to build Kubernetes
flows without having to worry
about learning Kubernetes.
Similarly on the
data science front
as well, I mean, there
are engineers who are just
starting learning data science.
They have a lot of good
background in Kubernetes
and systems, but they might
not be that familiar with data
science.
We want to create a low
bar for them as well,
have tools that will
enable them to build data
science machine
learning products
without having to go
too much into detail
of learning various
technologies if possible.
OK, with that in
mind, I would like
to present an example
which will walk us
through the user experience
that we just talked about.
It's specifically focusing--
I think a lot of you are
already familiar with what
a GitHub issue is.
Generally if you go
to GitHub, I think
there is a content associated
with the actual issue where
you have all the details.
And then you label--
your title the GitHub
issue with a title
that seems to fit or
describe, summarize,
what the issue is all about.
The problem we are
going to be looking at
is essentially a
user filing a bug.
And when they are
running into some issue,
they are not in
the right mindset,
and they are really troubled
about what is going on.
And all they want is
to paste that error,
provide whatever information
you want to provide,
and then file the issue.
That might not be the
best time to think about
what exactly is going
on and what should
the real title for the bug be.
So with that in mind, one
of the data scientists
at GitHub, Hamel, actually
thought about this problem
and felt that he can come up
with an ML algorithm or an ML
model that will
look at the content,
analyze it, and hopefully
suggest a title that
is relevant and helpful.
So I want to thank
at this point Hamel
from GitHub, who actually
built this model,
and Ankush and
Michelle, who helped
production this into an
application on top of Kubeflow.
And while I'm at the
stage of thanking people,
I should also thank a
whole lot of other people.
None of the content that you're
seeing is actually my creation.
It's a lot of people who have
actually helped create it.
And I personally really
want to thank Jeremy, who
is around actually right here.
You should please
meet him when you can.
He's our tech lead of Google
Kubeflow engineering team.
And he conceptualized,
formulated
the idea around Kubeflow
starting in 2017
and then in December
2017 announced
this to the world along with
the product manager, David
Aronchick, who's not here today.
So the two of them
co-founded this project
and really defined the vision
and the technology that
will go into making
this happen and to then
say we rely heavily on them
to provide us the direction.
I would also like to thank
Google's Kubeflow engineering
team.
Without them, none of
this would be possible.
And of course the
Kubeflow community--
we really love our community.
They are extremely
inviting open, friendly,
and they help us a
lot with the figuring
out solutions to these problems.
All right, moving
forward, the first step
that we were talking about
in the user experience
was deployment.
And this is something
really fresh, actually.
This is not directly
available so far.
But I want to give you a preview
of what deployment experience
would look like with
this application
that we have been building.
And this deployment
is a deployment
of Kubeflow on top of
Google Kubernetes engine.
As I mentioned, you can deploy
Kubeflow wherever Kubernetes is
deployed, whether it's
Microsoft Azure, AWS,
or some other
[? cloud-oriented ?] on prem
hardware.
But we are specifically
focusing in this presentation
on a GKE-based deployment.
You start with a few
[? set of ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
You talk about providing
information about the Google
project, cloud
project that you want
to deploy the stack on, and
give the deployment a name,
and then provide some kind
of authorization information,
and then be able to
say click deployment.
And a few minutes
later, you should
be able to view
your cluster along
with the services running
on your Kubernetes engine
dashboard.
So what this is showing?
Sorry about the small font.
But essentially, these are
some of the core services
that Kubeflow deploys
on your cluster
when you create the deployment.
A lot of these are fundamental
to stitching together
your workflows or your process
to train or deploy a model.
The URL here that
you are looking at
is essentially a way to
get into an access point
into your Kubeflow
cluster deployment.
Everything by default,
the way it is deployed
is protected in
your cloud project
and not accessible from an
external IP with the exception
that we create this
ingress point which
has IP protection, Google
IP protection, that
allows you to access and
authorize any access that
is going into the cluster.
So if you click on
that link, it takes you
to the Kubeflow dashboard.
Right now, it's very minimal.
And we are working
on figuring out
what is the right information
that should go in here
and what all makes sense.
But at this point,
it kind of like
helps you bounce
off to a few things
that you are most commonly
going to be doing.
The first thing that
it will help you get to
is the JupyterHub, which is
where you will be actually
doing your development.
And that is the next step
in the deployment process.
I do want to take some time
here and look at referring back
to our principal that we talked
about of low bar, high ceiling.
We created the UI, web UI
driven deployment process,
to lower the bar on
deployment to make
it easy for data
scientists who are not
familiar with Kubernetes
to get on to Google Cloud
and be able to
create the Kubeflow
cluster without much
effort, just a few clicks
and a few keystrokes.
But on the other hand,
we want to ensure
that anybody who's familiar
with what's going on
has complete control on
what their deployment is
going to look like.
So on that front, the
CLI based deployment
uses kftctl, which is
our command line tool.
And it lets you
control your deployment
with four sets of
commands-- init,
generate, apply, and delete.
We see an example of how that
workflow goes for deployment
on the right side.
So we start with initializing
your deployment and it ends up
like reading a few parameters,
environment variables,
determining what your
cloud configuration is
going to look like, and
then creates an environment
variable.
And init's a directory
which is going
to be your Kubeflow application
referring to your Kubeflow
deployment.
Once that is done,
then you can--
and in this instance
again, it is
pointing to a GCP,
Google Cloud Platform.
So it will end up
creating a GKE cluster.
The next step is basically
generating the platform.
And what that generate
does is it generates
a lot of configuration about
what your GKE configuration is
going to look like.
The benefit of this is that that
generated set of configuration
is available locally from
where you are doing deployment,
and you have access
to that configuration.
You can go and look in there
browse around what's going on,
and you are able to
tweak a lot of stuff
and modify things if you want
to create additional load pools,
you want to add [? GPUs ?]
right from the beginning.
You can make a lot of
configuration changes in there,
whether you want to have
IEP or not, essentially.
And the next step is going to
be apply the platform, which
would actually take the
configuration that it generated
in the previous step,
and then actually talk
to Google Deployment and
Cloud Deployment Manager
and create the GKE
cluster that was
defined by the configuration.
The next step is going to
generate the k8s about--
which are basically
configuration
for the various services that
are deployed on a GKE cluster.
So in one of the previous
slides when we looked at the GKE
cluster, it had a
list of services
that are running as
part of core Kubeflow.
The configuration
for those services
is generated by this command.
And apply would again
go ahead and apply that.
But intermediates--
it allows you
to keep that
configuration available
and modify in whatever
form you feel is needed.
Switching back to
the Jupyter notebook,
you go to the JupyterHub.
And this is the page you
land on which allows you
to create a Jupyter notebook.
If you notice here,
the first field in here
is letting you choose
a container image.
We have a few pre-built
container images.
These are Docker
container images
which already have a TensorFlow
support for different versions
of TensorFlow along with the
images built for CPU or GPU.
If you want, you can just
click Spawn at that point
and then say, like,
start my notebook.
But it also allows you to
configure further and specify
how many cores you want.
So if you know your workload
is going to require GPU,
you can go ahead and specify
that you need GPU containers.
And then you can specify how
much memory you might need.
Once you've created
your notebook,
you are inside the notebook.
And this is kind of your
playground where you go around.
You can import
TensorFlow libraries.
If you are working
with some other Python
libraries, PyTorch, you should
be able to PIP install packages
here as well.
And then you have access
to those packages,
Python packages.
You have access to Pandas,
whatever other Python tools you
might want to use.
This is where you will
spend a lot of time
iterating through your model
and figuring out what works,
what doesn't work, and
how do you want your model
to look like connecting
to various data
and actually
training your model.
Remember that at this
stage, you are still
running inside your container
that has got the Jupyter
notebook running.
So you're only working possibly
with a reasonably sized data
set that will allow you
to iterate and experiment
on your model.
Once you have figured out what
your training script is going
to look like, the next
step in the process
is to build a Docker
container image.
Currently, the process involves
defining a Docker file which
will specify what your
Docker container needs
to have installed.
So for example, if you need to
install a few Python packages,
you will have corresponding
PIP installs in there.
And then you copy in
your training script,
Python transcript, that
you had from your notebook.
You can create a
corresponding Python file,
and you can include it
in your container image
along with any other supporting
libraries you might have
written that you want in there.
And once you have
specified the Docker file,
then you will use
Docker Build command
to build the Docker container
image and then G Cloud
to push it to Cloud from where
you can actually then use
the container image to
create your training jobs.
Another thing I do
want to call out here
is looking back at the
low bar, high ceiling.
I think for a few
data scientists,
this might be too much.
They are probably
capable of doing this.
But is this where they should
be spending most of their time?
Which is why we are
thinking of integrating this
into a workflow that goes
directly from the notebook,
and you are able to take
your training exercise
and, from there
itself, click on Build.
And then at the back of
this, it will actually
create a container
image for you.
So there are different
ways we are thinking of
based on the feedback we
are getting on how we can
lower the bar at every step.
All right, so let's
look at the next step,
which is the most
exciting part--
for me, at least--
is to take my training
script and actually run it
on a distributed cluster,
creating a full scale
TensorFlow model.
In any application that you
deploy in a Kubeflow cluster,
the way it works is--
and I will go a bit more in
detail in a few more slides.
But essentially, it involves
generally two steps--
creating a configuration
for your training job
or any other service that you
want to deploy on your cluster
and then essentially
making sure that you
have that configuration's
parameters specified
appropriately based
on what you need,
like how many workers you
might need, where the model's
input is going to come from,
where do you want the output
model to go, and
setting up sizes
on what your
training set is going
to look like maybe possibly.
Once you have your
configuration ready,
then you can kick off your
training job by saying,
take this TF job configuration
that we just defined
and apply it on my
Kubeflow cluster.
And that's the ks apply
command which actually takes
the configuration, then talks
to the cluster and says,
bring up these containers.
Get it running.
And while that job
is running, you
would be able to use
various Kubeflow commands
to monitor the parts
that are running the job
to access the logs and
figure out what is going on
with the training job.
Back to the same--
I keep coming back
to the same theme,
but essentially, looking back
at low bar, high ceiling,
we do want to allow data
scientists or anybody who
actually just wants
a bit of flexibility
and ease to be able to go and
create their TensorFlow job
configuration from a UI.
And this is really
possible because if we
look at the previous
slide, there
was a lot of configuration
which is defined for the job.
And we can literally interpret
and parse the underlying
configuration and generate
the UI corresponding
to that configuration
and allow you
to set the parameters
not from the command line
but from the UI.
And here you should be able to
point to the container image
that you want to use, how
many workers you want to use,
and where to pull the
data from, et cetera.
Great-- once our model is
trained, the next step for us
is how do we solve this model.
I believe the example
that I present
here is to kind of use
Tensorflow [? serving. ?]
And you could use
Selden as well,
which is available in Kubeflow.
And we have a
GitHub Examples repo
that you can go and take a
look at for the GitHub issue
summarization example.
And then you should be
able to look and see
how the same thing can
be done using Selden.
In this slide, I will walk
you through TensorFlow
[? Serving ?] to
serve the model.
We talked about this
ksonnet that we use.
I want to give you
a bit of background
on what's going on over there.
We use ksonnet, which is a
configuration language which
allows templating to describe
various configuration.
And the power of
templating allows
you to parametrize a
whole bunch of things
that you can specify and set
and modify your configuration
at the time of instantiation.
So all Kubeflow
components are described
by a corresponding Ksonnet
configuration, which
is available to you on your
configuration directory
that you created when you
were deploying the cluster.
From there, you should be
able to create services
by generating new service
components using the template
and then configure the
parameters as I'm doing here.
We generated a
ServeInception component,
which is a brand new component
from the TF serving template.
And then we're setting
a few parameters here,
talking about whether we want
an HTTP proxy, do we want to use
GPUs, where the
model is actually
going to be stored, where
to load the model from.
And there are a bunch
of other parameters
that I'm not using but you're
free to explore and figure out
what you want to configure.
And then the last step,
just like last time,
is once your configuration
is ready, you say ks apply,
and then it will
actually end up deploying
this component on the cluster
and bringing up your model.
Finally, deploying a
web app around this
is a very similar process.
You would end up probably using
Flake or some other Python
library or whatever
is your favorite tool
to kind of build a web
app against the model
that we just created.
And once your
application is ready,
you can create a corresponding
container image, deploy
the container on
Kubeflow, and then you
have your UI to your
model [? at ?] the back.
I think I've been mentioning
this over and over,
but essentially, that
is the real theme
here is that we have been
working on making sure
that we get the breadth
of the components that
are necessary across the whole
spectrum of the workflow all
the way from data ingestion
to deploying and running
your applications.
There is a lot of
work around this, more
than we can handle
by ourselves, which
is why we are relying a lot
on our community to provide us
solutions as well.
And we would encourage you
to get involved as well.
But while we work on this
breadth, we do study our users
and get a lot of feedback
and figure out where
they are having challenges.
And we will leverage
that information
to drive lowering
the bar and improving
the experience on
wherever we see there
is pain in user experience.
We have tremendous
momentum, I think,
since the project went
live early this year,
late last year, early this year.
We have over 1,000 plus commits
now, 100 plus community members
that are active, and
roughly 20 plus companies
that are contributing.
And you can get live stats
about this from our GitHub repo.
Finally, I do want to
mention Kubeflow is open.
We are an open community.
We love people joining our
community and contributing.
Open design, open
source, and we are
open to ideas,
which is why we are
hoping that more and more
data scientists get involved.
As I noticed today, there
are very few data scientists.
I would love for you to go
to our website kubeflow.org,
go to our GitHub
repo, file issues.
Let's start there.
Why don't you file issues
on what is working or not
working for you?
And then we'll get
you more involved.
And hopefully, you will
have ideas to contribute.
Happy to take some
questions if you guys have.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Abhishek.
One question I
had is earlier, we
talked about different companies
creating their own ML pipelines
and things like that--
Uber's Michelangelo,
Facebook's FB Learner.
How generalizable are
you guys designing this
and do you think that this, the
way you guys are designing it,
could potentially apply
to use cases they have?
And how are you guys
kind of optimizing
between being opinionated
and being more general?
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Right, I think
we are starting from a place
where we are not opinionated.
And we want to allow
the flexibility
and allow the community to
kind of come up with ideas
and contribute.
I think the biggest
challenge at the beginning
is to kind of get the
breadth and make sure
that we have components, we have
support to cover the whole end
to end workflow.
I think one of the biggest
challenges if people are
interested is data connectors.
This is a big pain point
for all enterprise solutions
where people always
ask us, like,
can we have connectors
to our data systems?
And similarly, I think you
mentioned Michelangelo,
Facebook's FB Learner.
All of them have
various strengths.
And I think we are welcoming
them to come and contribute it
to the [? OSS ?] community and
build it into the platform.
We would love to have that.
Not only those-- if anybody
else wants to build--
we have a lot of contributors
who have gone and, like, made
the effort to take
their components
but make them available.
And we would encourage
to continue to do that.
AUDIENCE: Hey, thank
you for the talk.
So one of the issues
or one of the things
that can help that
doesn't exist today
is to know what the
standard we are doing
MLS because there is none.
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: And how to do feature
engineering, how to do serving,
how to do training, and if
we are doing it in a way
that it is compliant
with the enterprises--
then being opinionated
then actually helps.
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So how
do you see this?
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Right,
I'm not disagreeing.
I think your question
is very valid,
and I do hear this from a
lot of customers we talk to.
A lot of them are
at a place where
they are tell me
one way to do this,
and that is what I want to do.
I don't want to
explore and figure out.
So we do see a
spectrum of people
where there are really
sophisticated engineers
and teams that are actually--
they want full control.
But there are people
who are actually
interested in, like, this
is my business problem.
That is what I want to
focus on and just tell me
how to kind of like do this.
I do see a time when being
opinionated would help.
But I feel like at the
beginning of the project,
it is not the right
time to form opinions
where we won't even know
what the right opinions are.
I think it is time for us
to kind of explore and allow
the community to contribute
ideas along with us producing
ideas as well.
And hopefully, we find
out from our users,
from customers,
what works for them.
We are willing to help them
set up when they are confused
or if they need some
handholding and guidance.
We are willing to
put that forward.
Our whole community is happy to
do that in providing guidance.
But I think I don't
believe that--
if we start being
open ended right now,
I think we will end up
losing some good solutions,
and we might end up
creating a platform that
is not usable by all.
I think the whole ML
space, in my opinion,
is at a place where
as an industry,
we don't really know what the
right way to do all the things
are.
And we need to
figure that out first
before we can start imposing
those opinions on people.
AUDIENCE: Good evening.
My name is Paul.
Thank you for the information.
It seems like a really great
tool to help a lot of people.
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I've been hearing
a lot about KeyStores.
And I'm curious how Kubeflow
would play with like KeyStores
or managing identities.
ABHISHEK GUPTA: OK.
AUDIENCE: I know that
you have like an IAM
in the Google Cloud Platform.
Can you speak to that?
ABHISHEK GUPTA:
Right, I think we
are relying for identity and
access management to be--
on the underlying
cloud platforms.
For example, Kubeflow
itself is not
reinventing the wheel on
a lot of underlying cloud
infrastructure.
So on Google Cloud, we
rely completely on--
in fact, we will rely
heavily on Kubernetes
to design and define those
solutions and leverage that.
And in addition to
that, when you deploy
Kubernetes on different
cloud providers,
we will be leveraging
the IAM solutions that
might be available over there.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes, thank you.
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Thank you, Paul.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you could
help us position Kubeflow
against some of those managed
machine learning platforms
and how you see it from
the Google perspective.
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Right.
I think it will be a
good idea to do that.
There are definitely users,
as we just discussed,
who can benefit from
managed services as well.
And I think it's an important
part of their experience
where they are willing
to experiment and go deep
into certain areas.
But there are portions
of the ML workflow
where they would
not want to invest.
And it would be
great to integrate.
I think that also ties into the
question that Mark, I think,
had asked about how do we get
FB Learner or, for example,
Michelangelo or maybe Google
Cloud's manage offerings
to integrate into the platform.
I think it is
important for us for us
to figure out integration
points with those services,
for example.
People might be
willing to spend time
and are OK with things failing
or experimentation going on
in training phase.
But they want to leverage the
strength of Google's [? CLE ?]
platform for serving.
Or similarly, there could
be other managed services
that might be providing.
So I think that's an interesting
idea and very useful as well.
We should definitely look at
all those solutions as well.
I would not discount
any of those.
Does that answer your question?
Cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
mentioned at the beginning
that [INAUDIBLE]
Kubeflow [INAUDIBLE]
deploy not only on the cloud
but also on the other clusters.
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: Can you currently
deal with other kind of cluster
systems like HPC systems?
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Right,
that's a good question.
So I think, I mean, we
rely heavily on Kubernetes
to provide us the
capabilities on deploying
on different platforms.
And on prem is, for
example, one such platform
where we are working
with certain partners who
are focusing on making
this work to work on
like high performance
clusters, for example,
if there are InfiniBand
connects or if there
are other kind of interconnects
that, for example, Cisco
has some high bandwidth
connections as well.
So we would rely on some
of our community partners
to help us port these platforms
onto those hardware platforms.
AUDIENCE: This is currently
still not available
[INAUDIBLE]?
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Right.
I am not aware of this, but
I do know that, for example,
certain of partners are
working on the solution.
Right, but this is
certainly something
that we are interested in.
Thank you.
PRESENTER: Thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
ABHISHEK GUPTA: Thank you.
Thank you, guys.